[Musique]
les trois pas soufflé plantations
arrivée vous leur dites c'est quoi ces
élèves de primaire ont bien retenu la
leçon de botanique vue ce matin en plein
coeur du domaine archambault pour le
lancement des week-ends nature ils sont
les premiers à profiter des ateliers de
plantation et de découverte de la faune
et de la flore turlan dans les
plastiques de la planche
il vient de la plante et voilà donc là
c'est l'occasion de découvrir deux
patrimoines sur un seul site
c'est assez exceptionnel donc patrimoine
historique et patrimoine naturel et on
va voir dans les plantes endémiques
indigènes on va voir aussi des
problématiques donc les menaces 1 qui
sont sur ces milieux naturels à du 7 au
25 octobre auront lieu les week-ends
nature placée cette année sous le thème
de l'année internationale de la santé
des végétaux
une vingtaine de sites d' espaces
naturels et réserves marines se visite
accompagnée par des gestionnaires et
parfois de manière insolite visiter
certains sites en kayak on peut les
visiter à cheval on peut les visiter à
vélo cette année au sirop à pied
toujours évidemment mais voilà c'est
accessible ouvert au plus grand nombre
donc des personnes porteuses de handicap
les personnes âgées donc à des sites qui
sont qu'ils sont
organisé pour pouvoir accueillir ce type
de public
pour plus d'information sur les
activités proposées rendez vous sur le
www.defirh.fr 4 point fr
[Musique]